what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and today we have some
really big news about marvel's phase
five if you are wondering about the
future of marvel studios what projects
are up and coming and the path that
marvel is going to take well it looks
like we don't have to wait that much
longer to learn about this future marvel
studios has a lot in store for us some
things we might expect and some things
you might not expect like yesterday we
got an announcement for the thunderbolts
movie and the reports state that this is
going to be somewhat of a suicide squad
movie something that people may not have
expected also we do have a little bit
more info about the thunderbolts movie
coming to the mcu which we will talk
about in this video but i also want to
talk about how marvel is about to do a
major reveal for their upcoming projects
both movies and disney plus shows this
isn't like disney plus day where they
only talk about things that are coming
to disney plus we're talking about
diving into marvel's full future and it
looks like we're about to get some major
reveals so let's talk about what we can
expect to be revealed from marvel
studios all the projects that have been
rumored to be coming up and the projects
that we know that just don't have a
release date yet like the fantastic four
in the x-men so if you're new to the
channel and you love marvel and want to
stay up to date on everything be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
now disney plus day is coming september
8th of this year which is really
exciting but like i mentioned disney
plus day is about disney plus content
yes we can expect some reveals maybe
some trailers about future upcoming
marvel and star wars projects but we're
not getting any big reveals about movies
however marvel and lucasfilm for the
star wars fans are planning to go all
out in a really really big event that is
d23 now we've talked about d23 a little
bit before but today we have some really
exciting new details it really does look
like we're about to get some really epic
things from marvel in september and they
have revealed the specific date for
marvel and lucasfilms panels they are
going to be on saturday september 10th
so right away mark your calendars for
september 8th and september 10th because
this is when we're going to be getting a
lot of reveals from disney and marvel
but check this out like i mentioned
before marvel is planning on going all
out why because this is the first
in-person d23 since the pandemic so they
want to come back with a bang in fact we
have some news today that may make some
people happy but some people upset but
it does come with exciting news that
they are going to be showing a lot at
d23 it has been reported by one take
news who has a great track record with
scoops that marvel studios is going to
be skipping san diego comic-con in 2022
this year now for those of you who may
not be too familiar with san diego
comic-con this is typically where marvel
studios reveals everything in fact the
last time marvel studios was at san
diego comic-con was in 2019 where they
revealed the entire phase 4 list and
it's also where kevin feige talked about
the x-men and the fantastic four
i didn't even have time to talk about
the fantastic four
[Applause]
there's no time left to talk about
mutants
[Applause]
so san diego comic-con is typically
where marvel studios reveals everything
they reveal their future but according
to one take news they are not going to
be attending this year and the reason is
they are planning everything for d23 and
side note this actually really gets my
hopes up for an actual fantastic four
announcement kevin feige over a year ago
came out and teased the fantastic four
he said that they had their director and
that it was in early stages of
development now since then we lost our
director john watts who directed the
spider-man homecoming trilogy but
reports state that marvel studios is
searching very hard for a really big
director and they have met and are
meeting with some really big names so
since kevin feige mentioned the
fantastic four before said it was in
early stages of development and now
they're meeting with directors i hope
they at least reveal the year in which
we are going to get the fantastic four
film but let's talk about what we can
expect reveal-wise from marvel studios
at d23 since apparently they are
planning to go all out now we just got
word yesterday that a thunderbolts movie
is actively in development over at
marvel studios they even have a writer
and director for the movie already and
while we already assumed that some type
of a thunderbolts or dark avengers movie
was happening since valentina allegra de
fontaine showed up we didn't know that
the movie was actively being developed
so it makes you wonder what does marvel
have up their sleeve for phase 5. well
keep in mind marvel has revealed a lot
for phase 4. and here's the cool thing
we actually already have release dates
for marvel's movies coming up in the
next couple of years however we don't
know which movies are going to be
released hopefully this is something
that we'll get from marvel studios at
d23 here are the release dates october
6th of 2023 november 10th of 2023
february 16th of 2024 may 3rd of 2024
july 26th of 2024 and november 8th of
2024 here's my guess on what we could
get from these dates october 6th of 2023
could be deadpool 3. we know that ryan
reynolds has been working on this script
for a very long time now and we know
that deadpool 3 actually has new writers
attached to it as well so i'm assuming
it's pretty far along plus not to
mention we've gotten several teases for
deadpool 3 which leads me to believe
that it is coming sooner rather than
later now the november 10th spot in 2023
i think could be blade blade was
announced in 2019 san diego comic-con
where they announced that mahershala ali
is going to be playing blade and we know
that they have the director and the
writers for blade and they have for some
time now so much like deadpool i'm
assuming blade is going to pop up sooner
rather than later now february 16th of
2024 could be captain america 4. captain
america 4 with sam wilson as captain
america has been confirmed at this point
in time we're just waiting for a release
date so perhaps this could be it now in
the may 3rd spot of 2024 i'm guessing
that this is actually going to be the
fantastic four just like blade the
fantastic four were announced at 2019
san diego comic-con however a little
over a year ago kevin feige came out and
announced that the project was actively
in development so the middle of 2024
seems about when the fantastic four
should be done and like i said i'm
hoping they give us an official release
date for it during d23 now as far as the
july 26 spot of 2024 is concerned i'm
hoping this is spider-man 4. kevin feige
and amy pascal over at sony have already
confirmed that they are already working
on a spider-man 4 movie with tom holland
jacob babylon and zendaya and the
spider-man franchise in the mcu has been
massively successful they're not going
to want to stop that and not give it too
much time before we see our next
spider-man film yes they're gonna want
to take a little bit of a break but two
and a half years is a pretty good time
and now as far as that last date is
concerned november 8th of 2024 it's hard
to guess it could be the thunderbolts or
it could be a movie like shangchi 2
which has been officially confirmed to
be coming now keep in mind there are
several projects that have been
confirmed by trade companies like
deadline or variety that marvel hasn't
officially announced yet like the nova
film or the daredevil series that is
coming to the mcu and here's the really
cool thing about getting disney plus day
only a few days before d23 on disney
plus day marvel studios can focus on
their disney plus shows they can do all
of their reveals all of the footage they
want to show all of the trailers on that
day for disney plus shows then at d23
they can focus on feature films which is
what i think a lot of people really want
to know about at this point in time what
big movies does marvel have coming up
and i'm hoping that they have something
completely unexpected
up their sleeves they've revealed things
in the past that we didn't expect like
armor wars or iron heart or the agatha
house of harkness show being announced
and i hope we get something like that
too now as far as the thunderbolts are
concerned we have a little bit more
information about it today some of you
may remember the old scooper roger
wardell pretty much everything that this
person posted came true and a long time
ago in 2018 he tweeted don't worry
marvel still has big plans for zemo
ghost justin hammer general ross and the
abomination the leader is being
discussed to return as the main villain
of the thunderbolts which is being
planned as a trilogy now considering
that this person's track record was
pretty much 100 i'm assuming that this
is going to be pretty much accurate and
that the thunderbolts is not just going
to be one film but an actual trilogy and
i for one would love to see justin
hammer return and perhaps we will see
him return in armor wars after all what
we know about that show so far is it's
going to be about what if the iron man
technology got into the wrong hands so
justin hammer could very much appear and
we've already seen the abomination back
so i'm assuming this is pretty accurate
so expect zemo ghost justin hammer
general ross maybe not so much since
william hurt died rest in peace and the
abomination to return for a trilogy
which is very exciting and hopefully
we'll learn some actual information
about this upcoming trilogy at d23 so
mark your calendars and let me know how
excited you are for the future of marvel
studios and d23 in the comments down
below don't forget to give the video a
like and subscribe to the channel so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
marvel news for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof